our guest on c-span's newsmakers this
week is Tom Steyer the businessman
philanthropist environmental activist
has been spending much of his own money
over the past year in a campaign to
impeach President Trump we're going to
talk to him about that effort
organizationally and politically and we
have two reporters in our studio to ask
questions meet miles Standish of the
hill and Darrin Samuelson of Politico
gentlemen thanks for being with us as we
get started here mr. Stahr two questions
just on the mechanics of it first of all
what are the numbers on your website so
far how many people have you enlisted in
your campaign to impeach the president
I think we're somewhere over 3.6 million
people at last count I haven't looked at
it in the last couple of days guys have
been out of town but I'm sure it's over
3.6 my other question is you're running
ads and markets which is a centerpiece
of your campaign have any of the
television stations refused to run your
ads I think it's been reported that Fox
is refused to run our ads a couple times
and as far as I know everybody else has
agreed and and what is your reaction to
the reception you've been getting in
these markets from the station owner
honestly it's much III would say this
has been we have tapped into something
much larger than we thought we would
when we began our original goal was to
get a million signatures we it happened
much faster than we would have thought
it's kept going much longer than we
would have thought and of course every
time we get more than we expect we raise
our goal so right now our goal is to get
to five million signatures but when we
originally started it was 1 million and
we thought that that would be success
well let's turn to our two reporters
who've got many more questions to ask
we're gonna begin with Darren Sanderson
I'm curious you spent a lot of money
obviously in the 2014 and 16 races to
try and help candidates who supported a
lot of your causes what's your budget
here for for this impeachment campaign
it is an endless budget do you have a
limit on how much you intend to spend
well we actually don't have a firm
budget for it as we don't really for any
campaign either I mean our first of all
you should understand what
we basically are is a grassroots
organization which means we do a lot of
organizing on campuses we do a lot of
door-to-door conversations with voters
we do a lot of registration so what we
really are trying to do in our effort is
to have the broadest democracy with the
most engagement the most participation
by the most people and that's what we
really believe in so when we think about
our the impeachment campaign it's really
to try and give the American people a
voice to say this president is dangerous
to us and our families and communities
and he needs to go and so in that as it
goes we've already accomplished we've
gone way past our original goals and so
if we were set you know before it
happens I don't know what we'd be doing
so every time we get into something we
know the facts will change and so
therefore what we're gonna say well how
much we're gonna be involved what paths
we're gonna take changes to reflect the
facts on the ground so far twenty
million dollars you've spent is that
right something like that and do you
have any sort of sense just immediate in
the immediate future how much more you
think you're gonna be putting down I
don't because you know as we go what
we've seen when we originally started we
originally started this I think on
October 20th and a lot has happened
since since October 20th all of the
things happening with the Muller
investigation have happened in terms of
manna fort and Flynn the president has
done a whole bunch of things and our
original conception when we began was
here are the facts on October 20th and
they're going to change every day from
now on and this petition this drive for
impeachment is going to be sustained and
stronger as a result of the facts that
happen going forward and that's what we
found and just to pick up on that point
I mean there has been support from a
certain number of Democratic lawmakers
for impeachment but the Democratic
leadership in Congress has been much
less enthusiastic about focusing on that
topic or on that goal do you feel that
they are too timid what your what's your
response to the message that Democratic
leaders are
sending back about this effort well what
they've said publicly is they don't
think this is the time for it and what
we've found you know as I said we're
really a grassroots organization we're
trying to communicate directly with the
American people and give them a voice
and I don't think it's any secret the
this president is not a secret his
danger to the American people is not a
secret what he's doing on a daily basis
is is apparent to almost every American
so from our standpoint not to try to
counteract his danger not to try and
stand up to the threat to the American
people to us this is an urgent issue
where we're just telling the truth and
we're asking them we're trying to allow
Americans together to state that truth
so from our standpoint we're not trying
we don't really understand the political
calculation about whether this is smart
or dumb what we're trying to do is
what's right right but you think this is
right and important so the fact of the
matter is we don't think we don't think
it's a secret to the American people
that this president is scary so I don't
even understand that argument but not to
get hung up on this point
whenever democratic leaders as you
rightly or accurately characterize them
as saying this is not the right time you
think they're wrong in saying that well
obviously we're doing it now so yeah we
think that we think that this is an
urgent issue to the safety of Americans
and there's no time when we're gonna put
say we don't think we should stand up
for the safety and health of Americans
because it's not a good time politically
to do that no we think this is an urgent
issue and everybody knows it and if you
look at what's happened since October
20th in terms of people showing up at
the polls and the results of that I
think Americans are pretty aware of
where they stand on this issue and
that's why we've had the response we've
had mr. Stahr I actually do want to
follow up one more time sorry to belabor
the point a bit but some quotes from
Democratic leaders don't suggest timing
but something other for example I wrote
down a comment unhelpful a vanity
project futile when you hear those kinds
of
critiques of your effort what are you
hearing well I hear two different things
I hear one that it's not good timing
which I was talking about before and the
other one I hear a question about
questioning my motives and trying to
question me and I think you know from my
standpoint I don't spend any time on
that that isn't a bet this isn't about
me this is about whether what we're
doing is right and it's about the
American people having a voice in this
there's supposed to be a democracy we
believe we're trying to provide an
avenue for the direct voice of the
American people so the fact that if you
go take a look at the zip code of the
people who are saying those things and
where they spend their time from my
standpoint we're trying to talk to
people all over the country we're trying
to allow them to have a voice I'm not
going to spend one second worrying about
people who do an ad hominem argument
when in fact they should be dealing with
a question of whether this is true
whether it's urgent and whether it's
right one of the people who she was just
quoting was I think Nancy Pelosi who's
represents where you're sitting right
now what does she told you about this
effort what have you heard from Chuck
Schumer what have you heard from the
Democratic National Committee about your
effort we really don't have a
conversation about I've really never
talked to Nancy about this I don't think
a single time the fact of the matter is
we are trying I mean I would say it
again
you know from our standpoint we think
the strongest power in the United States
should be the voice of the American
people and that's what we're trying to
enable and activate and we think that
ultimately that's going to be an
overwhelming power we're seeing it we've
seen it in the elections that have
happened between the time we started and
now we think that that's going to
continue to grow and build and we think
ultimately that elected officials have
to respond and in fact if you look when
we started on October 20th there were
two people in the house who'd spoken
publicly about impeachment they held a
vote a few weeks ago fifty-eight voted
for it and four abstained so that's a
move I don't think that that's a fluke I
don't think they care about what I say
either I think what they're seeing is
Wow the American people are exercised
about this and they're right the
American people
are exercised about this I are you
trying to make 2018 a referendum on
impeachment in other words I don't think
there's gonna be any question but that
2018 is going to be a referendum on this
administration and the kind of extremely
negative policies and divisive racist
you know arguments that they've been
making that's what 2018 is going to be
about I think it's also really important
when we think about that the 2018 not
just be a negative campaign and a
referendum on the bad things they're
doing but also a referendum about what
they're the good things that they're not
doing that they should be doing that are
also killing us because as far as I'm
concerned as upset as I am about the
danger they pose to the American people
what they're not doing also threatens
our future because the fact of the
matter is they are attacking the
American people both by what they do and
but what they don't do but should do and
so I think it's important to have a
vision of what a better America would
look like the kinds of policies that
would actually make us successful in the
21st century just to play devil's
advocate on this to a certain extent
Bill Clinton obviously Republicans tried
to well did impeach in fact in the in
the 1990s admittedly very different
circumstances but there's certainly
conventional political wisdom is that
that effort by Republicans backfired
produced a kind of defensiveness of
Clinton among Democrats and centrists
and do you have any fear at all about a
push to impeach Trump actually
backfiring on the kind of causes and
coalition's and politicians who would
support well actually from our
standpoint I'd go back to first
principles now and what we're really
interested in is the broadest democracy
we're really interested in as many
Americans being registered engaged in
participating in our public life so when
I think about that and I think about
your question 10
me if we think what we're saying is true
is urgent and is incredibly relevant and
if that's true then that means that
Americans will respond to that they will
respond to the truth they'll respond to
someone standing up for the truth and
they'll be much more likely to come out
to the polls in response to that so no I
don't worry about what you're saying
because what we're we're trying to
represent a truth for the whole American
people and that includes everybody and
we think if we can do that
that is something that will compel impel
people to be engaged and to show up and
when that happens we the broadest
democracy we think we get the best
decisions and that's what we believe in
in our bones are you saying I just want
to keep on this for a little bit are you
saying that 2018 should be a referendum
specifically on impeachment that if the
Democrats are to take the House of
Representatives that that's the first
thing that they should do and that's
what people should be turning out for
the post were not Trump and everything
that he as you just described in terms
of the the policies and the things that
he was talking about but is is it
specifically impeachment I didn't say
that what I said was whatever we like or
don't like the 2018 election in my mind
is going to be a referendum on this
administration this Congress and their
negative backward-looking policies
impeachment is a statement that what
they're doing is so dangerous so unusual
so out of the box
that we actually have to get rid of this
president that is a very unusual
statement that that's a statement of how
far beyond what is safe this
administration has gone and the American
people need to speak up so that their
elected officials know that that's what
they want so do I think so in answer to
your question I believe this will be a
referendum on what this administration
with the support of this Congress has
chosen to represent including their very
divisive and hate-filled language and
that that will be it and that
impeachment is a statement of how
strongly Americans feel about it and
what they think the solution to it is
staying with the future elections but
shifting gears a little bit it's no
surprise to you that your own political
ambitions are the subject of some
speculation are you would you be
inclined to run for office yourself
anytime in the medium term what I've
said is that I haven't ruled it out and
that I'm actually trying to determine
what will have the most positive
differential impact of me working on
this and I know everybody thinks that
that's being clever but it's not because
I'm absolutely ambitious to try and be
part of the group of people who gets
America back on a just and prosperous
course I'm dead serious about it to me
that is what I get up in the morning
thinking about and I've said I'll do
almost anything that I think will get
will be the most differential positive
thing I mean it's not all about me I
there's a whole bunch of people I
believe the preponderance of Americans
agree with me and this is our time to
stand up and get us off this destructive
course and back to the kind of just
America that we've tried to be for
hundreds of years but this is so I
you're asking me what is the I know that
I have to make this decision fairly soon
and all I'm saying is the question to me
is what can I do to stand up against
what I consider to be a deep threat to
the safety and health of the American
people and not to get us off the news of
the day but I think this is a really
interesting argument because it goes to
the whole debate that always happens in
progressive circles or conservative
circles about or is one more effective
on the outside putting pressure on the
political system or working within the
political system for change
it do you have a broad view on that on
that question which gets raised again
again well let me say this what I said
before and part of what I take into
account in making the decision is the
organization that we've built over the
last five years so if you look at 2016 I
mean I can talk about 2017 too but if
you look at 2016 we were on 370 college
campuses
with our partners in labor we knocked on
12 and a half million doors we
registered eight hundred and seven
thousand people in the state of
California biggest registration drive in
the history of California and about
350,000 people outside California we
have a very large grassroots
organization designed to try and get as
many Americans involved and
participating in our process as possible
because that's what we believe in so
when I think about running for office I
don't think about just running for
office I say to myself we have an
organization on the ground that is
already working in 2017 for 2018 what
are the other things we could
conceivably do so when I think about
differential impact
I really am thinking about you know what
can really what can our organization do
that will make a bit you know will make
a big difference what can we do in terms
of the need to impeach campaign in terms
of signing people up you know at our
website and using that voice and using
their voice to try and push our country
forward so it's not simply a question of
you know shall I go on c-span or shall I
run for office it's really what can we
organizationally do what can we do to
collect and organize Americans together
so we get the broadest democracy for the
best answers so it's a little more
complicated than just run or don't run
let me jump in for a time check we have
about nine minutes left in the
conversation gentlemen you have I think
I think two or three more months really
to decide in the state of California
whether you'd run for Senator or
governor what's the next couple of weeks
and months like are you going to wait
until the very last minute on the filing
deadlines for the for those two
statewide races I don't think so I mean
my expectation is that you know we
really we've been doing and I've been
doing a lot of soul-searching in terms
of what I just described you in terms of
considering a bunch of things away from
running for office and what that would
look like and what the you know the
likelihood is of having impact with it
and what you know we can build for the
future and I don't think that that's the
kind of thing you know I know what the
filing deadlines are to
and I know that that's an absolute
deadline but the fact of the matter is
we if we're going to do some other
things we've got to make plans and get
them organized because running a
grassroots organization which is what we
do is not something where you can just
turn it on and turn it off grassroots
means you're organizing people you're
hiring them you're training them you're
setting them out in the field they're
then organizing groups of volunteers to
do all the work it's not so it's
something that takes advanced thinking
and preparation so we can't wait to the
filing deadline you know we've got to
sit here and make these decisions and
and weigh the different alternatives as
you talk about grassroots maybe one of
the things you have now in your
possession is maybe one of the most
valuable email lists that Democrats have
right now in terms of people who signed
up to support him impeachment it could
be you know as valuable as the Bernie
Sanders list from the 2016 period what
are you doing with that list are you
gonna make it available to other
Democrats are you hoping to you know put
it out there on the on the market for
for people who are looking to run in
other campaigns I mean what we've done
so far I mean really what we've been
doing is going to those people and ask
them to take actions I mean that's the
first thing we've done is ask people to
say will you send an email to your
Congress person will you you know
respond to this tax plan those kinds of
things and you know I'm not sure we
didn't it is true that people signing up
gives us communication with people but
the fact of the matter is what we also
are trying to into it's not so much
we're trying to use them we're trying to
let their voice and their collective
voice be heard because for Americans
they are scared by this president they
don't know what to do in between you
know November of 2016 and know November
of 2018 which is the midterms and so the
question is how can we use the
collective voice of Americans to change
the debate to explain to elected
officials where the people really are
that they purport to represent and to
let that voice be heard so that the
American people's will can be followed
that's what we're trying to do and
that's what that list is really for is
to
is to say this is these people can be
together an incredibly strong voice for
change and that's you know that's the
whole reason for a petition is to
explain to people look this is these are
the American people if you look at where
they are they're all over the country
I'm just a curious tall I mean you've
made the argument in this interview
several times about the the power of the
people giving voice to the people and
all of that
you obviously are someone who has
enjoyed a lot of success in business you
are yourself personally very wealthy and
man which enables you to do some of
these things where do you stand on on
the importance of money in American
politics is it still does it still have
too much influence oh my gosh yes
oh my gosh now it's killing us money in
politics if you look at it but you're
you're spending quite a lot of your
money right we are and I will address
that too but let's just start with this
tax bill for one second that we're
seeing a tax bill that is a pure
response to Republican donors we're
seeing a tax bill that absolutely
supports the richest Americans at the
expense of everybody else as far as I'm
concerned the American people just had a
steamroll or go right over their head
and in order to deliver money to the
richest Americans so is there too much
money in politics today is the proof
positive that there's too much money in
American politics and when I my original
response to this was I want no part of
it and then I realized oh my gosh these
are the rules of the game this is I
absolutely disagree with Citizens United
I absolutely think it's that this is
distorting our politics it's getting
away as I say to a democracy of dollars
instead of a democracy of people and
that's terrible for us but it's the
rules of our democracy right now and so
what we're trying to do as we spend
money and we're doing it for dirt as
much as possible to get the broadest
democracy possible we're doing it as
transparently as we can
I'm sitting on c-span explaining to you
what we're doing in
so there's no hidden agenda here and
we're not doing it this I'm fighting a
tax plan which is delivering money to me
our organization is trying to work
directly for the good of the American
people not for the profits of rich
people and definitely not for my profits
so the fact of the matter is I do think
this is an incredibly distorting feature
of American politics and we're actually
seeing the culmination of it this very
day we have just three minutes left so
last questions
I'm just curious I mean people do not
necessarily know who Tom Steyer is
outside of California they've certainly
seen a lot of the commercials that
you've run but your name recognition has
increased from what I understand you're
being recognized as you make your way
through public spaces nowadays President
Trump attacked you on Twitter talk a
little bit about sort of your own name
recognition increasing was sort of that
underlying question that we really
haven't gotten to which is are you
running for president in 2020 but that
combination of all of those things right
now and whether you're seeing your name
recognition now increasing well let me
say this I'm one of the luckiest guys
around and I'm lucky because I was born
in the United States I was born to a
family that really took care of me I got
a great education I'm a white male in a
society where lots of people have been
discriminated against for in some way
shape or form not being that so I
recognize how much luck I've had and I
also recognize that this system is the
product of literally hundreds of years
of people sacrificing and sacrificing in
the most profound ways so I look at
myself and I say this is an opportunity
for me to be part of the group of people
trying to do something good for America
when the American people are under
attack from within and I look at that as
a incredible opportunity for me in terms
of having a meaningful life and being
part of that tradition of Americans
trying to move
the country in a good in a good way so
every part of this that works into that
I'm incredibly happy about if I can do
that
that MIT gives me enormous satisfaction
because that is what I think every
American for hundreds of years in their
heart of hearts has wanted to do and I
want to do and so I'm extremely happy if
this campaign moves us in that direction
and I can be part of that and I'm
extremely happy if I can be part of the
group of Americans working like heck to
get us back on a prosperous and just
course really happy about it now we have
about a minute you have a final question
well I had this very worthy final
question ready to go about whether the
impeachment campaign is distracting from
your environmental interests but
listening to your last reply I just
think yeah he's he's running for
something am I wrong yes let me make one
point let me make a point to you about
this first of all it is possible in
American history that people do
something they think is important
because they think it's important and
secondly when we think about
environmentalism as part of the overall
political spectrum we think that
environmental change will happen as part
of a progressive change that goes around
a justice agenda so as far as I'm
concerned what we're pushing for is a
just America where people are more
prosperous it's more fair and we think
this is eminently doing we really
believe that what the Trump
administration in this Congress are
doing is something that takes away our
future by refusing to invest in the
American people and that is something
that we should absolutely be doing
because a successful country in the 21st
century is going to be dependent on
well-educated healthy well trained and a
productive human beings so we should be
investing in the human beings otherwise
known as the American people and not to
do it seems like a crime to me Tom
Steyer is the founder of the need to
impeach campaign joining us from San
Francisco mr. Stahr thank you for being
a guest on newsmakers and happy Holidays
to you thank you so much for having me
be holidays to all three of you well
gentlemen let's talk about this in the
larger political so because the
grassroots campaign with three million
signatures does face the reality of a
political structure and of which
Pietschmann
impeachment very much is
constitutionally bound so where is the
attitude on Capitol Hill you talked
about the fact that leadership is
pushing back on all this not giving it
credence even though a small portion of
the Democratic caucus has has managed to
enlist support about 30 members or so
where's it stand
I think impeachment for now is off the
table I think the Democrats while
publicly the leadership saying they do
not want to be talking about impeachment
they know that that is going to bring
out some segments of their base in the
2018 midterms but that is part of the
wave that they could hopefully
capitalize on they think in order to
take back the house it's a huge climb to
actually pull this off I mean there are
a lot of seats that they are going to
need so I think impeachment for them is
something that while they're sort of
head nodding we don't want to talk about
it we want to have a positive message
you know about the economy about the
things that they would do if they were
actually in charge no doubt if Nancy
Pelosi or whomever becomes the next
Democratic leader impeachment is the
question they're going to be faced day
in and day out especially if you think
about where Barbara Moeller will be you
know nine months from now ten months
from now where the entire congressional
investigation is going what more we're
going to learn about what happened in
2016 so well they don't necessary much
aware of it now let me ask David Axelrod
the Obama advisor has gone sort of at a
higher level of discussion calling this
sort of a threat to the democratic
process that it's damaging
constitutionally could you talk about it
at that level and any concerns you've
heard by people in the political process
about using impeachment in this way you
know it's interesting that you say in
the political process because I think
among political professionals of either
party things are so polarized that
people either want to impeach them or
not but the broader point that you raise
is an important one on people in
academia and journalism and other places
wonder about this idea that what happens
if we get to your point for simply
intense dislike of a president
Trump's or as a catalyst for impeachment
efforts can those impeachment efforts be
successful how damaging would it be to
set a precedent where a president is
impeached in those sort of circumstances
no clearly people like Tom Styer and
others don't see it that way they see
this present as very much one of a kind
as someone who transgresses the normal
democratic bonds of this society but I
think there is a genuine concern among
some others about setting a precedent
for removing a president from office
simply out of a popular enmity or
dislike there and anything to add on
that point I'm just thinking it's
fascinating with Tom Styer in California
where the recall effort brought down
gray Davis and led us to Arnold
Schwarzenegger in 2000 and was maybe
2008 or 9 the recall process does not
obviously work in the presidential
process but this is sort of what he is
arguing for most as a political uprising
to take out a president clearly they
would need actual crimes and
misdemeanors high crimes and
misdemeanors as the is the bar that they
would set and whether it be the
obstruction of justice case that top
accuse me of Robert Muller is pursuing
and we don't know exactly where that's
going at this stage of the process
sitting here in December of 2017 we
don't necessarily know how far that is
it's right now for Muller it's been
mostly focused on campaign aides and
what they did in years before they were
even in the Trump campaign so I think
there's a long way to go before we
actually get to that threshold of high
crimes and misdemeanors and maybe Robert
Muller will provide that in a report
down the line the same way that Ken
Starr produced a report I think that's
what we need to watch for and what has
the White House reaction been you
mentioned that Donald Trump has tweeted
about Tom Steyer but does anything more
formal going back or are they
essentially ignoring this campaign as
it's going on I think they would regard
this as something that is counter to the
wishes of the American people who did
democratically elect Donald Trump one of
the whole fixations of this White House
and I think Darrin would agree is the
idea that there are shadowy things going
on behind the scenes to rob him of his
victory or to D legitimize his victory
at the President did I think called mr.
Stahr unhinged at one point which is the
kind of lexicon of the president trades
a lot but the broader question is one or
the broader issue is one in which they
fear these efforts and see them as an
attempt to undercut at the president's
democratic legitimacy one quick question
there was an election on Capitol Hill
today as were taping on this Wednesday
before Christmas of in the house a
Democratic caucus Jerrold Nadler will
take over the lead role for the
Democrats in the House Judiciary
Committee which could becomes very
important and especially if the
Democrats are successful in their effort
to take over the majority in the house
do we know anything about Jerrold Nadler
attitude towards the impeachment process
and that it would add to this discussion
I think for now he is taking the lead
along with what you've heard from Nancy
Pelosi and other Democrats is let's let
the process play out let's have a more
proactive positive message but Nadler
has been bird-dogging the chairman of
that committee robert Goodlatte
criticizing him he just did again today
as Goodlatte goes after FBI officials
and starts to sort of turn the Russia
investigation sort of on its heels and
flip it upside down by starting to look
at things not necessarily related to the
ill to the Russian collision but looking
back at Hillary Clinton and the FBI so
now that has been on their case on the
Republicans case he's also trying to
push that investigation forward in terms
of just looking at obstruction of
justice obviously if now there was in
charge I think you would see a much more
intense campaign to try and figure out
whether obstruction happened again he
wouldn't necessarily be taking over the
chairmanship for 10 11 months from now
and things are gonna be in a very
different place than they are right now
well thanks to both of you now standing
of the hill and Darrin Samuelson of
Politico for being our questioners this
week of Tom Steyer on newsmakers thanks
thank you